All right, so welcome everybody to today's Zoom call.
We got some, a lot of questions, like I said,
that were sent in and again, a reminder to all of you.
Listening to this, if you have questions,
you can email them to your liaison
or to the Qatar's clinic Gmail account
or to my info with Qatar's clinic Gmail or email account
and we'll try to get to them.
So I think we got, I think I got most of your questions
that you were emailed in, asked.
Always another reminder, please,
when you have a question to first go to our website
and look at that little high glass key
and type in your question there.
You may find a blog post or a page or a mention of
to find your answer.
So that might be a good resource too.
So just to remind her again, first question.
What does it really mean when tumor markers go up
and do tumor marker labs increase
during heavier detoxification?
So again, if you don't know what tumor markers are,
go back to here and search tumor markers
and you'll find a blog post about tumor markers.
But what does it mean when tumor markers go up?
So we'll talk through that a little bit.
So you guys understand.
So tumor markers are, get to where I can type in here.
Tumor markers are an enzyme that some cancers give off.
So some cancers give off this enzyme
and that can be picked up on a blood test.
There's multiple tumor markers
who would go to the back of that blog post
to learn about what tumor markers are.
But that enzyme that can be elevated if a cancer is growing.
So one way that could be an indication
that you possibly have a cancer,
if you don't know you have cancer,
if you did a tumor marker test
and you have elevated tumor markers,
you better start looking for do I have cancer?
There's other reasons why tumor markers can go up.
So but if you have cancer and you did show
elevated tumor markers at one point in time,
then you could utilize tumor markers as an indication.
As what are the indications that there could be cancer
that's growing?
So what are the reasons why tumor markers can go up
as that your cancer is growing?
So that's not the reason that we all want to hear,
but it is true.
So tumor markers can go up if the cancer is growing.
So that's why you do that test.
So you go, wow, maybe it is.
So, but that being said,
you have to take that test and weigh it against other findings.
So one test isn't a diagnosis
and one test doesn't tell us everything.
So you weigh it against subjective findings.
How are you feeling?
I feel great, I've been running five miles a day
and you know why I have no decrease in energy,
my no-dreaters had appetite, but my tumor markers went up.
Could be that your cancer's growing
and you haven't felt it yet,
but you have to use the accumulation of data
when you make a decision in your treatment plan.
Tumor marker goes up and you're feeling great,
could be just the tumor marker went up.
Could be another reason why the tumor marker went up.
If you take that data, my tumor marker went up
plus my fatigue is worse, I don't feel good.
The tumor feels like it's growing
if you have a palpable tumor, you weigh it out with other data.
If that's true, then we want to make sure
that at least from our clinic perspective,
we wanna do some retesting.
So doing some retesting in our clinic,
we would get another cheek swab done for sure.
So if your tumor markers are going up,
let's check your cheek swabs.
Remember, we're just doing everything we possibly can.
That's our promise to you.
We will do everything we possibly can
to make changes in your body.
So sometimes we do everything.
You do everything humanly possible
and your cancer still grows.
It's just a fact of life.
Sometimes we need to constantly be tweaked things.
So cancer is constantly trying to find a way to grow
and we have to do everything we can to make changes in that.
The second reason why a tumor marker can go up
is the cancer is dying.
So if cancer is dying,
then your tumor markers will go up too
because it's an enzyme released by a cancer.
If the cancer is dying quickly,
then it can spill out more of those enzymes
and you can have a rise in tumor markers.
Well, how do I know?
How do I know if this is a good thing?
A good sign that the tumor markers
went up for a bad sign that the tumor markers went up?
Well, there isn't a perfect way to know,
but you do measure it with other tests,
subjective and objective tests.
The subjective test would be how my feeling,
things that we discussed is my fatigue worst.
It's my appetite worst.
How my mom will let's you look at all your subjective
findings and there's other objective tests you could do.
I can also do the viral test.
I'm going to do a CT scan.
I can do an MRI.
I'm going to do things like that.
So you look at those things.
Remember with any laboratory work,
there is a positive negative 3%,
5% of range that can vary.
So you could do a tumor marker.
Let's say you do a CA 99 or a CEA and I say it's 3.6.
And you do a CEA tomorrow and it's 4.3.
And you do it the next day and it's 3.5.
And then the next day and it's 5.7.
So you got to understand there is a range of fallibility
in these tests.
If it spikes way up, then there's pretty good chance
that there's something going on.
So we need to check into it.
Could that be the cancer growing?
Could it be the cancer dying?
I don't know.
You measure it with other things,
the subjective things we talked about,
the objective things, other tests we talked about.
And you just have to weigh out those things
when you make a critical decision making process
if you're going to change what you're doing
or tweak what you're doing.
So it could mean that the cancer is dying
and you don't know because you have to measure that.
Same thing with number one,
you have to measure that with other things
that you're doing, other signs and symptoms
that you're experiencing.
So with any test, you measure with other signs and symptoms.
And number three, a cancer marker can go up for other reasons.
Let's say you're measuring CA 99.
Well, CA 99 is commonly elevated,
even with non-cancer patients.
It can be elevated with bile obstruction, for instance.
So bile obstruction can raise CA 99.
If you have pancreatic cancer with bile obstruction,
you're going to have raised levels of 99,
even if the pancreatic cancer isn't growing.
So there's other reasons that a tumor marker can go up as well.
And then lastly, it can be just test error.
So if your tumor markers have gone up
and you're like, boy, I feel great,
I don't know why this has gone up,
it might be good to wait a week or so and run the test again
to see if it comes back differently.
If it's still just as elevated or even more elevated,
then maybe start doing some more investigation
if there's something else going on.
To answer the second half of this question,
do tumor marker slabs increase with heavier detox phases?
Not really, but again, that would go back to
if you are doing a lot of work in detoxing different therapies
that you might be doing.
Saunas, different copyinabas and different things like that.
You could be falling into the number two here
that the cancer is dying,
and that's racing with tumor markers as well.
Okay, next question.
After the last cheek swab,
I was supposed to start Artemisidin solo.
Excuse me, that's a brand that we have.
I was supposed to stop Artemisidin solo.
Will this be harmful to start it again
since I need it with the reacted iron?
So this person is, I believe,
talking about the iron protocol.
So if you have to take iron supplements
because you have low iron, low hemoglobin.
So if you have a low hemoglobin or low iron,
excuse me, throw.
Then it might be wise to take iron.
Well, the problem is that iron can be
a fuel source of the cancer.
So if you're going to take iron,
then we suggest you always take iron
with Artemisidin.
So yes, if Artemisidin didn't test necessarily
for your cancer,
still take Artemisidin with iron.
The reason is that Artemisidin typically tags with iron.
So if iron is being used as a fuel source
for the cancer,
then the cancer will suck up Artemisidin directly.
You're using iron basically to drag Artemisidin
to the cancer.
If the cancer is feeding off iron,
you could help kill the cancer.
So still do the Artemisidin with the iron protocol.
Yes.
I'm still having abdominal gas pain,
but during this heavy detoxing phase,
suggestion for relieving gas.
So remember gas is caused from fermentation
of carbohydrates in your gut.
Now this happens with everybody.
Nobody doesn't have gas.
But you can have excess gas.
This is something wrong.
Oh my gosh, I got the worst gas in the world.
What should I do?
You got to look at how am I digesting carbohydrates?
Am I digesting carbohydrates well?
So if I'm not digesting carbohydrates well,
I will have excess gas.
So what do you do to help digest carbohydrates?
Well, understanding how carbohydrates are digested.
So carbohydrates are digested mainly through,
initially through actually through the enzyme
that's released in your mouth as you chew a carbohydrate.
So you're chewing your food.
You are releasing a patellin from your salivary gland
that's starting to digest carbohydrates.
Then carbohydrates go into your stomach
and HCl in your stomach is digested carbohydrates.
When people have excess gas,
often it's from their eating excess carbohydrates.
But they can also have excess gas
because they have a deficiency in HCl.
So my first step if I have a lot of excess gas
is to start taking an HCl,
hydrochloric acid supplement with your meals.
So if you take HCl with your meals,
you are going to have a better chance
of better digesting carbohydrates.
So we always recommend the HCl'sime
because it has a digestive enzyme also
that helps digest carbohydrates.
So taking HCl'sime with your meals
can help break down carbohydrates
so you have less gas formation in your gut.
You can also have excess gas for other reasons.
You are producing,
you can have a dysbiosis of your gut,
the imbalance in different healthy probiotics
and your gut healthy, healthy microorganisms
in your gut that just imbalance.
So those are producing excess gas
and die off of those is producing excess gas.
So you can't get gas when you're doing detox
if you're dealing with that.
So another product to think about
if you're not taking that is to change
from the fiber, like a sun fiber, decrease sun fiber.
So you're decreasing your consumption of that
or if you're taking sun spectrum, decrease sun spectrum
and change to using an SBI protect.
So SBI protect will more clean the gut out
that fiber can break down and cause more gas production.
So that's another thing to look at.
So two major components there, increase HCl with your meals
and change from a fiber supplement
so after taking sun fiber or sun spectrum,
change will lay off of that right now
and go on an SBI protect product
which is gonna help kind of sweep the gut and clean up the gut.
And then lastly, think about adding a probiotic
if you're not taking a probiotic.
So those would be the three main things
if you're dealing with a lot of gas.
I'm still dealing with queesiness
which makes it difficult to eat.
I'm doing a ginger tea that could help ease it.
I don't, do you have any other suggestions?
So queesiness and nausea,
there's another nausea question in here
that we could address at the same time.
It's very difficult can make it very hard
that you even want to eat anything
and that can lead to cakexia.
So we don't want that.
We don't want people losing too much weight.
So yes, ginger can be very helpful.
I had this maybe not to the degree
that some other people are having it,
but it just bothered my stomach really bad.
I used a product an essential oil
from a young lady that was called dijis.
That helped me.
Now I know other people don't like that
because it's too strong but it is a strong oil.
I put a drop on my finger.
I just put it in my mouth.
I did that multiple times a day.
I carried dijis at my pocket for a long time.
That really helped me.
There is the not now nausea spray
that other people have used.
I did not use that because the dijis worked for me
but that would be another product to try.
Succeed on ginger shoes can be helpful.
You can get ginger shoes at even a target
and it's mainly sold for expected mothers
with pregnancy sickness.
So that's another thing to do.
So anything that can calm down your stomach,
peppermint can work for some people as well.
So think about adding peppermint as a supplement as well
to using peppermint tea or peppermint essential oil.
As well, that could be helpful.
There is a nausea program on the right.
I haven't found that to be super effective though.
Steel daily with hip pain and not constantly CBD THC
tincture has not helped.
I've tried your limitless beat product.
That didn't really help either.
I've noticed I'm not trying the CBD pain tincture
do you think it might help?
If the CBD didn't help, the CBD pain tincture
probably won't help.
So I don't know if I'd call that route.
Part of the pain appears to be muscle.
So it's been doing massage in that area.
Hot baths can bring about some really too.
I would think about doing epsom salt baths.
That can be helpful as well.
And if you have, so other things to think about
with pain like this is using some other modalities.
So think about using a tens unit.
So a tens unit is transcutaneous electrical
neurological stimulation.
It's used for chronic pain like chronic disk patients.
Tens unit, you can buy it from our site.
I think they're like 40 bucks.
It comes with little sticky pads.
They're meant to be used 24-7 if the person wanted to.
Typically they get to be a little irritating after a day's use.
So you turn it off for a while and you can turn it back on.
But they just run on a battery and I'd won't battery.
They last forever.
They're great little units to break the prayed cycle.
What those do is they stimulate endorphins and in kephalins.
Endorphins and in kephalins help break the pain cycle.
And can be really helpful.
Other things that you could do for the pain
is other types of electrical stimulation.
So if you have go to a chiropractor,
they could do Russian Stim or other EMS type modalities.
If you have ability to use a PEMF,
a PEMF, a pulse electromagnetic field therapy
can be very helpful for pain as well.
And then other things that you could use for pain
is you can disrupt the pain with what's called brain-based therapies.
So brain-based therapies is understanding the neurology of pain.
So the neurology of pain is that you have something that's irritating a tissue,
fire, heat, a pain receptor.
So you have different receptors in your skin, in your tissues.
One of those receptors is hot and cold.
What is vibration? What is pain?
What is actually surface touch like a tickle or a stimulus
and a deep touch which would be pain?
So those pain fibers fire back in through your nerves
into your spinal cord.
They actually cross in the spinal cord
and there's actually another connection there in the spinal cord
that we'll talk about in a second.
And then it fires all the way up the spinal cord
to the brain and to the pride alone telling your body that you have pain.
You could interrupt that cycle a couple of different ways.
So one brain-based therapy for pain
would be stimulating other receptors.
So stimulating other receptors
would be like I said there's a vibration receptors
and there's hot and cold receptors.
So there's hot temperature receptors.
There's one of the advantages we talk about using cold therapy on a pain
that is to decrease inflammation.
Yes, cold will decrease inflammation, but cold actually stimulates hot and cold receptors.
So cold therapy putting an ice pack on a spot can help with pain.
But some people go go to say that actually makes my pain worse.
If I put a hot pack on it, it makes it better.
That's why I do it hot baths.
There are epsom-swap valves that are really helpful.
So you're going to have to try with your hot or cold
or alternating hot and cold can be good to help with pain.
Using vibration and you don't have to use vibration over the pain,
especially if you have a musculoskeletal source of pain,
let's say a damaged muscle or a broken bone,
you would put vibration over it, but you can vibrate another area,
typically downstream neurologically from that area,
meaning if it's hip pain, you'd put a vibration down at your foot
or you'd put your foot out of vibration pad,
or it can be the other foot out of vibration pad.
So you're stimulating the neurological pathway
that's basically competing with that pain pathway.
And so that's one thing that you can do for
using brain paste therapy.
The other thing you can do is you can stimulate
at a higher level in your frontal cortex.
So your frontal cortex is your frontal lobe of your brain.
That's right behind your temple, not your temple,
but right behind your forehead.
So that is your executive of the brain.
That's how you think thoughts and make decisions
by stimulating your frontal cortex.
It actually fires a pathway
back to the parietal lobe and get into hip pain.
That's why, so if you're in pain, you hurt yourself,
but you're concentrating on something else
that pain seems to go away or be diminished.
It's because of that pathway.
So God created this frontal parietal link pathway
to inhibit pain so that you can concentrate
on doing something else in the midst of a crisis.
So likewise, you can utilize that frontal cortex
to stimulate pain.
So how would you do that?
You have to do novel activities.
So novel activities, new things.
So how are you stimulating the frontal cortex
through novel activities?
If you're studying something, you haven't studied before
and you're learning something new,
you tend to get lost in the moment
and you don't feel the pain.
Well, it's actually that pathway that's being stimulated.
Well, how practically can you do this?
Well, one of the most practical ways
that you can stimulate novel activity is doing jigsaw puzzles.
Jigsaw puzzles are everything you might have done
this puzzle five times, but every time you look at it,
it's new, but you try to figure out where this piece goes
and oh yeah, it goes to the whatever house over here
and you're doing this thousand piece puzzle.
That could be a phenomenal way to help decrease pain.
I know it seems really weird,
but you're stimulating these pathways.
So by stimulating the frontal lobe,
you're inhibiting the parietal lobe.
Now to get to technical, by stimulating the frontal lobe,
you're inhibiting the parietal lobe,
but the parietal lobe is where you feel pain.
We could have a whole class on just how to deal with pain,
but that is one thing that could be really, really helpful.
All right, is it okay to do vitamin C, IV vitamin C
without doing a jigsaw?
Yeah, absolutely.
You can do vitamin C, IV without doing a jigsaw.
You can do anything you want to do without doing a jigsaw.
That's your choice.
So I remember the jigsaw is just our way of testing
whether that's going to be beneficial for you,
but if you believe that God's leading you in that direction,
by all means, go with that direction.
You don't need our permission.
So we're just your coach.
We're just somebody that's praying about your case specifically
and praying about what's best for you specifically,
but you're hopefully doing that as well.
And if God's leading you in direction,
to take this supplement or not take what we told you to do,
by all means, be obedient to what God's telling you to do.
I want you to be obedient to him more than I want you to be obedient to me.
We're going to say so.
Absolutely.
What do you think about the hoxy biomedical center at Tijuana?
I had a call with them.
I was interested in their internal hoxy treatment
do you know anything about them?
Are all the supplements I'm taking with you equivalent to their formula?
I'm going to do a consult with them.
Well, we do do hoxy
and we use hoxy-like formula in testing
and we utilize their herbal formula,
but what they might be right for you too.
So again, this goes back to the other question.
If you believe God's leading you in that pursuit
then by all means, listen to him and follow his leading.
I'm not here to say anything bad about any other, you know,
clinic that that God has leading you to do.
So by all means,
that could be complimentary to what you're doing with us too.
I'm just now getting my first IV and we had to have them
mix up a different bag.
So I assume they're going to IV vitamin C
because they talk about B complex
because my B12 was methylated.
Was this correct?
And can you tell me why I don't want methyl B12?
So yeah, so methyl B12.
So there are multiple forms of B12 on the market today.
What you're typically going to find in a bag of IV solution is
Cyanol cobalamine.
So cobalamine is the B12 component.
Did I spell that right?
I don't even know anymore.
Cyanol is the type of cobalamine that it's bound to.
This is a synthetic cobalamine.
Typically, this is going to be in all IV solutions
unless you go to a clinic where they're formulating at themselves.
The other form that everybody talks about
and has been so hot to try on the market is methyl cobalamine.
So methyl cobalamine is been the hot item in the nutritional circle since generic testing
came out and everybody is tested for the MTHFR gene defect.
So the MTHFR gene defect is methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase gene.
So that's a gene that, oh my gosh, you have the C677 defect
or the 1280 defect that we need to get you on methyl groups right away.
So we're going to put you on methyl cobalamine and methyl tetrahydrofolate.
And people have been often over-methylated.
So they're using supplements with methyl groups in it.
And true, if you have a MTHFR defect, you can be an under-methylator.
You can have issues with being able to methylate.
So what is a methyl group? A methyl is a carbon with three hydrogen atoms.
And it's necessary to make these methyl groups because they're needed
in your cells and they're needed in your body.
So one of the things that methyl groups do is they silence genes, they turn genes off.
The problem with that, with cancer patients, we don't want to silence
tumor suppressor genes. So you have different genes
in your body that when you have a growing cancer, these genes will turn up.
They're called tumor suppressor genes.
The bronca genes are one of the tumor suppressor genes.
The P53 genes are tumor suppressor genes. These are families of genes.
These are very important genes to turn on to help your body kill cancer.
So when a person has defects in these tumor suppressor genes,
while they're not going to be turning on in immune response to kill cancers,
as well as if you didn't have defects in those genes.
Well, likewise, if you're taking a ton of methyl groups,
you are going to be silencing these genes even if you don't have defects in it.
So we don't want our cancer patients taking methyl folate or methyl cabolamine, at least not
very much of that. You're going to get adequate methyl groups in your diet.
So we suggest that you take a hydroxyl
cabolamine or a adenosyl cabolamine. So those are what we typically recommend that a person
take when they're taking B12. Also, I'm thinking I may have cakexia as I'm really skinny in what I
could do. So skinny is not that they are you losing weight. So pakexia is defined as
you're losing 2-4 pounds a week and you can't put the brakes on it. So if that's the case,
you make sure you make an appointment with me right away. So if your weight is stabilized and you're not
losing any more weight, but you're definitely underweight, keep doing what you're doing.
But definitely, if you're losing weight, you make an appointment with me.
I'm wondering if the PEMF or hypothermia would be beneficial for this person's talking about
their brother's diagnosis or adding hyperbaric. So we do test for these things, but even though we
test for them, doesn't mean that they wouldn't be beneficial. Yeah, it'd be beneficial if you're doing
a whole bunch of different steps sometimes, but then also you have the counter benefit of if it's
consuming your life and you can't even live in a joy life, well, then that's not good either.
If you have brain cancer, PEMF tends to not be the tool for you, nor does hypothermia. Though you
could use hypothermia on your liver, not on the cancer. Hyperbaric, if you have brain cancer, hyperbaric
is a therapy of choice. PEMF, great for pain, great for general health and increasing charge of
yourself. So PEMF is good for everybody, but if you're trying to kill the cancer itself,
the PEMF isn't the cancer killer. Hyperthermia is good for everybody because you can do it over your
liver, you can do it over other organs. It will help, but if you have brain cancer, hyperthermia
really isn't the tool for you either. Hyperbaric, hyperbaric oxygen is great for everybody,
but it's more appropriate for brain cancer than it is for breast cancer. So it depends on the type
of cancer. Ozone, I am not a big fan of ozone at all, and I've talked about that in multiple
zoom calls. Ozone is O3, and it's great for killing bacterial infections, great for a lime, it's great
for mold issues, not as great for cancer. So not what I would suggest for most cancer patients.
How do we know if patients are candidates for immutal therapy? So we're talking about immutal therapy.
We have to qualify that term. So immutal therapy, when we're talking about it from cancer,
is typically the medical immutal therapy. So the drug, like ketruda, ketruda is a brand name
of an immutal therapy, the most popular immutal therapy drug. So what ketruda does, what immutal
therapy does is it affects the cancer cell. So your cancer cells are your own cells,
and when your immune system is going to go and attack the cancer cells, one of the reason why
your immune system doesn't kill the cancer cells is because it is your own tissue. When your T-cells,
and specifically, that's one of your immune cells, goes to attack the cancer cell, the cancer cell,
basically connects with the receptor, the T-cell, and turns the T-cells response to the cancer off
because it's self-tissue. Now when immutal therapy does, it basically blocks that receptor
in the T-cells, so the T-cells will attack self-tissue. So one of the side effects of immutal therapy
are T-cells. One of the immune system cells are going around attacking self-tissue everywhere.
So it's not specific to the cancer. So ketruda blocks that receptor in your T-cells, so it doesn't
recognize any self-tissue, a self-tissue. So therefore, people taking immutal therapy end up with
side effects of having all these different autoimmune disorders. So it's attacking their gut cells,
so they end up with colitis. It's attacking their thyroid, they end up with Hashimoto's, it's attacking
their, so you can get all these weird symptoms anywhere in the body, anywhere. Your immune system
can start attacking your cells. One patient, she lost her hearing and her left ear completely after
taking immutal therapy, just one or two doses, and she said that's enough for this, I'm stopping.
It can be effective, though, with brain cancer, not so much because the
cell type that's helping kill cancer in the brain is not so much your T-cells, but it's more your
microglial cells. That gets into a whole other discussion, but T-cells, but immutal therapy, I know they're
starting to do some testing out of immutal therapy with brain cancer, but I just can't understand
the physiology how that's going to work, because immutal therapy is really working at T-cells, and it's
not really T-cells that is killing brain cancer, it's microglial cells.
But I'm very full of immutal therapy if they think it's going to work. Now you do have to get,
with most cancers, you have to get this test done to see if you have this type of
this type of cell type and gene type that immutal therapy will actually work with. If you don't,
you're not even a candidate for immutal therapy, so your oncologist would do that test.
This goes back to our nausea question. Extreme nausea, extreme fatigue, through four times on Saturday,
felt weak. Please be praying for this person. I've been in that type of state before, and you know,
you feel like you're not going to make it, so this person needs all the prayer in the world, so without
knowing that person's name, God knows this person's name, so I ask that everybody be a prayer for
this person. But you don't give up. So when you're in this state, you don't feel like taking your
supplements. So the question is this person has not been taking their supplements, and they feel like
that they're failure, and they're not really helping themselves, and they're not taking their
supplements. Don't think that way, just keep doing the right, keep doing your footpath, keep doing
your other things that you possibly can do. Don't worry about taking your supplements right now,
so just just want to encourage you to just don't give up. You just keep doing everything you
possibly can. Don't beat yourself up, but don't think that you're not doing everything you can,
because you're not taking your supplements. The supplements are just one piece of your care, so don't
worry about that. There's times that I went to week without having to be able to take anything,
I just felt like I was going to lose my cookie, so I just did not take anything. So that's okay.
So when we talk about in other blog posts about pulsating your supplements, so there can be times
where it's good not to take it, because it's kind of pulsating, so don't worry about that.
There are, make sure you reach out, I know, and we'll be calling you too, so we should have a chat.
Are you familiar with zappers, specifically the non-croft treks zapper?
This person is wondering if this would be beneficial to him or others.
Zappers are fine to use if you want to use it. To me, I don't have a zapper. I used to have what I
played with it for a while. I don't use a zapper. You have a rife machine, like a thousand times better
than a zapper. But there's lots of tools out there, but that's a good question.
So I'm not a big fan. All right, so some questions that came in on the chat.
Prepied for my next go-around with COVID. Planning on nebulizing hydrogen peroxide,
which you already said was okay for me, okay, to add lugal solution, several protective
practitioners. So lugal solution is iodine. Thermal practitioners say lugal is essential,
so I want to add it to my plan if you're okay with that. Yes, that should be fine too.
Next question. I know caffeine and alcohol interact with natural therapies. What are your thoughts on
drinking mushroom coffee occasionally? So I am all for drinking mushroom coffee,
even on a daily basis. So usually caffeine is, if you're just drinking a cup of coffee,
that's usually not driving anybody's cancer. So if you're drinking five cups of coffee a day,
that might be a different story. But then you're getting benefits of the coffee, even drinking,
let's say just drinking coffee without mushrooms. There's also benefits. It could help flush your
liver. It could help people with almond. So there's other benefits from just drinking coffee too.
But also there's actually a G2. So if coffee does make you have to urinate,
then you are flushing the caffeine really easy. If you could drink an entire pot of coffee,
and you still don't have to go to the restroom, then you don't detoxify caffeine very well,
and you probably shouldn't be drinking coffee as much coffee. But if coffee makes you have to go to
the restroom after drinking a cup of coffee, then you are detoxifying caffeine just fine,
and you could even drink more than one cup of coffee. If you add mushrooms to it, it gives other
benefits. So I like to add chaga to my coffee. I do that very regularly. I think chaga is very
healthy, and I like the taste of it, but then I like just about anything. So I chaga to your coffee,
or other mushrooms to your coffee, or this mushroom mix, or something like that to your coffee is very good.
Next question. There are three different kinds of inflammation frequencies on the right,
all 36 minutes. How do you know what to do? You just with any of the programs on the right,
you just got to try them. Try one for a few days. Boy, this one's really not helping me. Try another one
for three, four, five, six times. Oh, this one seems to help a little bit more. Try the other one.
Oh, this one doesn't help me at all. I'm going to go back to the second one. You just have to try
things. These are frequencies. There's no perfect way to know if that's going to work for your inflammation,
because there's lots of different causes for inflammation. The other thing, when you have a
condition like I got inflammation, you do want to start asking yourself, why do I have this
inflammation? Do I have inflammation? Because I have a virus, I have inflammation, because I have a
bacteria, I have inflammation, because I have an injury, I have inflammation, because I have the
cancer, and you want to try to treat the reason why, if possible, as well. At least start asking
your body those questions. It's not always the inflammation program that you want to run. Maybe it's
the viral program that you want to run. Any other questions? If you want to chat your question in,
if you want to speak your question, you'll have to unmute yourself for the first. I have a quick question.
So if I have a cold, as I do right now, do you recommend running the frequency for that?
overnight, instead of doing my regular cancer protocol? If so, then what day would I go back to,
once I go back to my regular protocol? That really depends on the state that somebody's in. So
you're doing really good at your relative state of remission. You're doing really well. You certainly can
skip that day and do a different protocol, depending if you're dealing with some other illness, for sure.
Then just go back to the day of the week that it is. So let's say on Wednesday night,
tonight, you skipped your Wednesday program and you ran all night COVID program. And then on Thursday,
you go back to your Thursday program. That's just fine. Remember your programs are not sequential.
They all stand on their own. So there's nothing wrong with missing it. Let's go back to the night
of the day of the week that it is. Another question. Do the benefits of hyperbaric oxygen come from
breathing in the oxygen? Yes, they do. Plus it's just to increase pressure through your skin too. But
yes, it is breathing in the oxygen. Yes. The next question. What are your thoughts on up tube?
For a deal for
geoblastoma, I think. And what is the Western doctor has put my grandson on?
So it's not called up to what is it called? So I don't know if you're talking about the
PEMF device that attaches to the skin where they shave your head and they put on these pads
that are sedated of frequency across the brain to interrupt with cell biosis.
So the way cells divide is through myosis. And so during the process of cell division,
your chromosomes have to separate to opposite sides of the cell.
So when a cell divides, brought one of the processes of cell division as your chromosomes
separate out to opposite sides of the cell. And then the cell basically splits down the middle
and now you have two cells. So the process of biosis is taking place. The idea with this new type of
therapy that's used for geoblastoma patients is they put on this PEMF device that's attached to your
head that you're ready and you're walking around with this handheld goes in your pocket or
out of your belt, this little PEMF device for excellent hours a day. And it's supposed to interrupt
with that cell division. It's shown to be actually very promising. So it's actually exciting to
it's increased. The last study I read it increased life expectancy by 15% or something like that.
So that's actually good with the last one. I'll get a couple of that with rife and nutrition
and everything else knows much better results. Okay, next question. What's the biggest difference
between rife frequencies you created for us versus the general cancer once in the rife?
It's some, there are the ones that we created for you and the ones that we tested for you. So there's
a lot of different frequencies in there. So the general cancer ones are just that. They're very general.
They're not specific to any person. And it's specific to the cancer as possible but not specific
to a person. When we test you we're getting specific to the testing as possible so that we create
a unique program for you. Can you speak about DMSO? DMSO is dimethyl sulfoxide which is became
very popular in the late 70s, early 80s as an anti-inflammatory agent. It's like water
and it absorbs like instantaneously through your skin and it does decrease inflammation. So it's
really common for knee issues. People would put DMSO on their knee and if they had inflammation
or injury and it went down, decrease inflammation, it could help with pain. So help people with
arthritis. So it's still used today for arthritis patients. The other problem with DMSO is if you have
lotion or chemicals on your skin and you put DMSO it would drive the motions of the chemicals
through your skin so you absorb them quicker. Which might be
counter indicative if it's a chemical that could be toxic. So you have to be careful of having
clean skin when you use DMSO. Or you can utilize DMSO in those qualities of DMSO as a driver of other
things. So you could mix zinc with DMSO and spray it on your skin to treat cancer.
You could put CBD with DMSO and put it right into the skin. You could use black sap with DMSO
to drive it into the skin and into the cancer. So you could utilize DMSO as a driver as well
because it's so well and quickly absorbed. Next question had two tumors removed and position
recommend the PET scan in three to six months. Are there alternatives to such as their biography?
So thermography yes can be utilized for indication of issues as well. I didn't know what kind of
problem. So thermography really shines with breast cancer. Thermography really shines with
head of neck cancers. Thermography doesn't really shine before a abdominal or colorectal, things
like that that way. So but you've got to remember any test sits on itself. So thermography is a great
screening tool to tell us how we're doing and you know if there's new growth possibly, new activity,
higher metabolic rate, but it isn't necessarily a substitute nor is PET scan a substitute for
ethnography. So PET scan has invasive qualities that are necessarily beneficial. Thermography is not
invasive. So thermography you could do every day. There's no way to take it a picture of the body.
So thermography would be the most optimal screening tool for breast, for head and neck
issues also for neurological issues as well but it's not going to be a perfect substitute for a
PET scan and you can't compare thermography with a PET scan if you're trying to compare apples to apples
their different tests. But yes, thermography can be a substitute in those type of cancers I mentioned.
Next are you aware of any of the box thinking medical oncologists in the Midwest?
Nope, sorry. I don't mean to be cynical there but the truth is is if you're an oncologist working
as an oncologist in the United States you're really for sake of a better term you're really bought
you're you're going to go outside the box thinking and do different outside the box thing you're
going to have to have your own clinic because you will be a trouble. Your license is going to be a
trouble. Most outside the box cancer clinics are not run by oncologists. They're run by medical
doctors or other doctors that are maybe have given up their license like me. I mean when we had our
license but I had my license I was so attacked by the board. That was the most stressful time of my
entire life because they're judge and jury over you and it was just horrific. They accused me of
everything under the sun and I had to admit to things I didn't even do in order to keep my license
because I thought I needed my license in order to practice. Well I realized I did it and I did
need to admit to things I didn't do so I have things on my record that I didn't even do.
But that was a long time ago and God used that to drive me to take care of cancer patients solely to
give up my license and give up that side of my practice. So God always gets the glory in these things.
But that being said for an oncologist to be an outside the box staker it's such they'd really have
to do the same thing and give up their practice and move to an alternative type practice on their own
and most of the time have to give up their license because the board would be after them constantly so.
A lot of frequencies on the right recommend a different ball than one that came with yeah so
don't worry about that you can use any ball that you need and understand Mike has true right as a
businessman and he's trying to make money he makes money selling stuff so he recommends different balls
so there's different times that we might recommend that person get the double bubble ball or some other
ball but 99.9% of the time just use the hammer to that's the only ball I have at home it's the only
ball I use but doesn't mean that you can't use something else so we do have patients that do buy
other bulbs do you ever feel like it would be good to retest for different right frequencies for a
patient yeah so you you could do that and request that when you do a cheek swap so for sure
X could you use DMSO with RSO yeah you could use DMSO with anything but if you're doing
you can't take DMSO poorly but we don't recommend that so DMSO is typically done topically so if
you're using RSO topically RSOs are exceptional so if you're using RSO topically you could add
DMSO to it or you can put some DMSO in a little spray bottle put the RSO on topically it sprays
the DMSO with the negative is that DMSO is very watery you know run down your skin so you might have
to put a gauze on or something like that so you just have to play with it how you're gonna use it
but yes you can use it to help drive in RSO or drive in anything where could I get
chaga mushrooms like you mentioned before in the coffee so chaga mushrooms we sell it in our store so
you could buy chaga mushrooms in a bag just like our medicine a mushroom product and just put it
in your coffee so put a teaspoon in your coffee every day that's great I put a teaspoon
or a heat-beam teaspoon usually in my coffee when I do it now it is grainy and some people don't
like to taste that but it doesn't bother me you could put it in a little tea bag and put it in your
coffee that way you could put it one of those little tea strainer things that you could that should
put other tea in it is ground so it might get through the little holes so you might want to put it
a little tea bag if that bothers you I just put it right in my coffee and I chew on the little
granules why ozone therapy is not good for tumors okay we discussed this multiple times on zoom calls
why I'm not a fan of ozone I'm not saying it doesn't work just saying from a physiological standpoint
ozone is all three all three is unstable that's the benefit of ozone it's unstable so
all from a molecular standpoint all two is stable with electrons that's what oxygen is all three is
unstable it's it's so it will freely give up what are the oxygen molecules to something if you're
treating cancer you do want to oxygenate a tumor but you oxygenate with O2 not not O with a negative
charge to it so it's you're basically creating free oxygen radicals with ozone now there's benefit
to creating free radical oxygen species in your body because radical oxygen species in your body
kill pathogens so you talk about free radicals in your body are damaging you don't want free radicals
in your body free radical especially your rep free radical oxygen species can cause cancer because
they can attach to cell membranes a damaged cell membranes they can get on the side the cells of
damaged cells they are oxidizing not oxygenating so oxidizing is free radicals damaging tissue
that's why you take antioxidants so you take antioxidants to get rid of free radical oxygen species
those are oxidizing agents so you get rid of oxidizing agents by taking antioxidants all sorts of
things in our environment cause oxidizing agents chemicals pesticides herbicides all these things
damage cells cause cancer free radical oxidizing oxidizing species cause cancer as well
ozone produces free radical oxidizing species and can cause cancer well why would anybody use ozone
that well because it also kills pathogens remember nothing in your body is always bad or always good
it's all has to do with balance and the reason why oxidizing agents in our body could cause
cancer is because they're typically out of balance that way we've talked a lot about chemotherapy
being an oxidizing agent poisons are oxidizing agents that's what poisons are so technically chemotherapy
is a poison but hopefully you're poisoning the cancer before you're poisoning the patient
but oxidizing agents so you think well that could kill cancer then too why can't ozone kill
cancer it's possible but you're damaging a lot of other tissues as well and you could be causing
more problems than not but you're using oxygen it really shines when you're trying to kill pathogens
so if you're trying to kill mold so ozone therapy can be very beneficial for someone with
mold toxicity ozone therapy can be very beneficial with lime patients I'm not a big fan of ozone
with cancer I'm not to say that there are practitioners out there treating cancer with ozone and it's
helping and it's working but that's just my opinion from a physiological standpoint all right are
gonna have to say goodbye for tonight because I don't know if my voice is gonna work any longer so
I asked that you guys all take some time on a daily basis and pray for all the patients that we have
pray for our clinic as well I ask thank you in advance for that and pray for your other family of
patients here as well everybody's going through different things some deeper struggles
that you have right now too so be cognizant of that to be prayed for people
power prayer is real and effective and it's it's a responsibility as well all right I love you all
and I'll talk to you again very soon bye bye